what's this Andrew Tate sparring gets
hit what why can't my man get hit you
know they waiting for him to fail so
much son he looks huge now that guy yeah
he gained weight in jail what the [__]
were they feeding him in there he said
I'm doing a thousand push-ups or
whatever and I was like that's cap and
now I'm looking at him he might have
been yeah yeah this [__] is huge
dude
yeah he's getting got but in the guys
it's all about small [__] but that he
you'll see
oh he's getting [__] up I mean he's
boxing in business clothes which is wild
it don't matter he's getting knocked Go
full screen miles you're about to see it
it's okay I got it
um
here we go slow as [__]
yeah there you go
all right those are all blocks here it
comes
blocked yeah I think it's this one
okay there it is a good body shot there
it is son I don't that don't make up for
all the time she got caught son yeah
dude caught a match they call him he
called him he got caught son looks like
a red pills that take us boy you think
has an L For Real
he did he did but I also think it was
cool that he posted that like it's easy
to only post your W's but like that is
true you stood in there you took some
shots and then you [__]
you laid a nice body shot that was yeah
that was nice yeah but yeah still so
what happens with with Andrew Tate you
think do you think that
let's say he gets off do you think he
learns his lesson and he basically goes
it's not worth going through jail and
house arrest Etc I can still make money
outside of this
I don't need the risk of my freedom let
me tone it down or do you think he goes
Super Saiyan I'm really curious because
my my first reaction is he's gonna have
to lean in even more
on some like kind of trump [__] but he's
smarter than all these other red pill
guys and he's you can't treat him like
most normal media person he's smarter
than most media personalities period
yeah so he could find a way to stay
relatively true to his brand and pivot
out of some of that quote-unquote toxic
[__] yes so I'm curious to see how he
handles it because it feels like right
now he's free mostly and he's being
pretty low-key because he has to be
because is the trial is still going on
or whatever so I'm curious when that
trial is over how is he going to handle
it him in particular most people I think
I would know they're gonna lean in
I wonder if there are Muslims because a
few of these red pill dudes like are
claiming Islam now I wonder if there are
Muslims out there that resent that yeah
and it's like oh you're getting some
heat okay yeah I'm mad yeah because like
oh you're getting some heat you're
getting some criticism for saying wild
[__] and now you're gonna use the Islam
Shield so that people can't criticize
and you make Islam look like the
womanizer's piece of shit's religious
exactly yeah so you you maybe it's
authentic maybe they did find God
through it and that's possible but it's
also possible that it is a convenient
Shield they can use in you know billions
of people that will support them in
their Endeavors but you are bringing all
your toxic [__] yeah over to an Islam or
over to a religion of peace and beauty
and it's nice that you're giving them
the benefit of the doubt but it's most
of them I don't believe it at all
because they're not saying they've
changed in any way it's hard to believe
it when people start looking like a
plastic bag in the winds
which is what a lot of these do Tate was
surprising to hop on to Islam because he
seemed a little bit more discipline than
a lot of these dudes but like when you
see the paper or the plastic bag in the
wind guys the guys who identity changes
every [__] two weeks right like those
are the dudes that you look at and you
go oh wow you're just wearing this as a
costume yeah this is a shield and that's
super insulting because that's people's
life yeah and they're giving you the
benefit of Doubt and they believe so
much their life and their afterlife in
the afterlife that's everything so it's
like and they believe so much in their
God and their religion that they're like
I imagine they're like okay
I see so much Beauty in this they must
see Beauty in it it's hard to be
skeptical of someone finding Beauty in
the thing that you think is the most
beautiful right so if I like a song and
then someone else goes yeah that song is
fire I'm never like nah he don't really
like it yeah because I love that song
right right so I I understand why people
welcome them with open arms as well
because they care so much about that
thing and they understand the value
behind it but yeah I haven't really seen
any Muslim people speak out about the
community kind of like hopping on board
yeah and taking all their [__] [__] over
there and please believe Islam does not
need any more bad PR especially in the
in the woman Department yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
like it's yeah you conveniently went to
my religion we don't need that we don't
need that exactly yeah we got to bring a
Muslim on here to talk about that
yeah I I agree and again I'm inclined to
not believe them because I don't hear
Andrew Tate saying like like Malcolm X
when he became Muslim and then went to
Mecca and you read his autobiography he
changes he stops hating white people he
says that he goes through a
transformation because that man was
about God and Islam and his faith you
don't see anything like that with Tate
so far
you know what I mean if I saw that I'd
be like yo [__] wow God bless man good
for you but when you don't see that it's
like oh this is your Shield to use your
word yeah this is really convenient all
right guys we're gonna take a break from
this exclusive patreon clip because I
gotta tell you all about the best
wallets in the business and that's extra
throw away your wallet throw away your
wallet nobody needs that George Costanza
nonsense you hold in peppermints and
that [__] you don't need that anymore
okay you don't even need cash anymore
but if you did want to have some cash
you got it on your extra if you got your
cards all on the extra convenient hit
that button pop up also boot protected
what do I mean by boot protected someone
just can't run up on you and steal your
information why the RFID protection has
got you back and you're never gonna lose
your wallet because they got a tracker
on it so think about that last watch
you'll ever need is right here now check
it
this does not need a discount at all you
should never have a discount on a wallet
this amazing but we're going to give you
a discount on it 25 off site wide with
the code flagrant when you go to
shop.exter.com flagrant 25 off-site wide
with the code flagrant at shop.exter.com
flagrant now let's get back to this
exclusive patreon clip watch the whole
patreon episode of patreon.com flagrant
subscribe join the [__] Army right
now a new episode every single week and
all you got to do is pay less than a cup
of coffee a month that's a no-brainer
it's kind of picky to watch it's going
to be interesting to see when uh trial
is over what direction it goes in
because like I thought he was making the
pivot to Islam
in preparation for the trial because he
felt like the walls closing so it's like
hey let me get ahead of it and let me
look like look I'm a God-fearing
individual all that stuff now after the
trial is done if he gets off
it'll be interesting I think he goes
crazy goes crazy in which way bad like
more red pill more this more that
because while also being mus Muslim no I
think he moves away from it like he'll
probably like it's it's easy to jump
into the Bell hmm I think it's easy to
jump in and jump out you can just still
say like all praise a lot and then still
just do all the [__] the [__] you
want
hmm I think it's harder to do that yeah
I think it's harder to do that with
Islam than Christianity
we'll see Christianity has become so
kind of like mainstream america-wise
that there's a lot of people living how
they want to live Islam the people who
are Muslim here tend to be very devoted
because it's a smaller number
so you don't see as many of them here
you know yeah I'm curious about over
there about Dubai and like I know we all
here like Dubai like if you want to get
down with the [__] [__] there's a place
to get down to function yeah yeah I
think there's breadville Community needs
him to lean in more I think if he leaves
the red pill Community it's a problem
for them as a whole he's propping up a
lot yeah
what do you think happens I don't know
it's hard to tell it's really hard to
tell
yeah the whole red pill Community thing
it's hmm
yeah it's really hard to tell I mean
everybody's grifting
right yeah and the problem with a grift
is that there's truth to every grift
every grift everything where there's
money there is truth there are people
drifting off abortion
and anti-abortion both sides and there's
truth to both sides so it it's not to
dismiss the feelings that people have
because those feelings are valid and
that's why we gravitate to certain
content and certain speakers and certain
ideas those feelings are real but there
are also people that recognize that you
can monetize those feelings yeah and
um
yeah uh you can usually tell if
somebody's monetizing if they've been
trying to make it for a while yeah and
haven't yeah and then all of a sudden
adopt a trendy ideology that is highly
monetizable yeah that's generally how I
telegrift you know so if somebody for
example like
and I don't know Candace Owen's career
so I can't speak on it but it let's say
Candace has been this exact same person
since she is 14 years old and it's okay
people can also change but let's say
she's been I I would go she's not
Grifton if she's making money she's
making money but that's her yeah
let's say Candace was one specific way
and then completely flipped as a trend
built I beg ooh that might be a grift
yeah I don't know
I think Candace really believes it and I
also think her superpower is her ability
to be hated and be unscathed most people
cannot be hated and unscathed and if
you're comfortable being hated there's a
lot of [__] money to be made I mean
but there is but in the web record of
her being a little bit more liberal back
in the day and people do change as they
get older they have kids Etc but like I
think with the red bill because it's
such a trend
you could see like I think that just
pearly things girl
do you know her I know of her the the
tall redhead girl I I think that's pure
grift yeah I think it's pure grift I
think that she's probably a girl that
just wanted to make it on YouTube and
um I haven't appreciate a video about
her right yes yes yes they're [__]
I've been preaching the [__] songs
I was trying to look at whatever he was
out in Miami but he was a little busy
but bro yeah they're the best but I
watched a video of that and like it kind
of exposed some earlier stuff but I
think that like a lot again a lot of
these ideas probably align with her
she's a six foot tall woman she's not
exceptionally beautiful she's not gonna
have the same empathy towards the
average woman and what they go through
now than some girl who's like pretty and
has a lot of people trying to date them
and is there she's probably gonna relate
to these dudes more she's getting
rejected yeah she's I mean not getting
the man of their dreams like everything
that she feels in the dating discourse
[__] dudes feel right
so it's like of course these ideas are
gonna line but the grift is saying hey
these dudes that are look at as if they
hate women
ain't wrong yeah and then the dudes get
to go see at least women agree with us
yeah yeah you can also just look at the
gray space in the market there's like a
void in the market for a woman who sides
with those guys is the equivalent of the
Candace Owens for white people there's a
there's a market for a black person who
agrees with all these people yeah there
are endless amounts of money
for non-white people that are willing to
tell white people they're not racist
yeah and there's endless amount of money
for non-males that are willing to tell
men that they're not sexist because we
always want to be told that we're
correct we're valid and to be fair
there's also money in pointing out in
non-white people pointing out white
people are evil not as much as well
because that's a more crowded Market but
that market exists and there are people
also tons of people Griffin on the left
yeah without a doubt there's tons of
people right
um and that can consume your identity as
well yeah yeah it's it's a
man yeah it's a tricky thing but that's
how I kind of look at and that's why I
like the Advent preach to is because
like
their their content you could say was
like red pill adjacent and then they saw
grifting in the red pill Community I
think and then they were like now we're
calling that out these dudes are corny
they very easily could have just
partnered up maybe maybe right like yeah
but they potentially took a loss to call
out what they thought was truthful yeah
integrity at the at the highest yeah at
the highest right there when you're
willing to risk your [__] to say the
thing that you want to say yeah
absolutely and the grifting you brought
up there's truth in every grift the
grifter will usually take the truth and
then take it to a place where it's not
really true sure but they use it to
defend it yeah and and then we act as if
it's an ideological argument which it's
not it's not we agree that these ideas
are valid 100
you just ain't in it for these ideas
facts you and it for the money yeah and
that's the same with like a religious
gift there is no question that the
belief in God is incredibly important to
human beings it has been since like our
beginning of Society we look for the
stars for something yes a hundred
percent the the what is it the
spirituality or the uh what did they say
that people said when I was in church
and I felt that feeling it was the Holy
Spirit yeah the Holy Spirit whatever it
is it's like yeah 100
there are also people
who recognize that you can make money
off of that yeah and might not believe
those things but are just trying to make
money and so we're not debating yeah
we're not debating the religion even if
they don't twist it even if they say
exactly how it is yeah let's assume
they're not twisting it they said
exactly what it is
but they're getting into it because
there's money to be made for example
it's like uh the criticism of like
vanilla ice and Hip-Hop yeah you could
argue that was a grift it's like yo
clean cut white boy who knows how to
dance we're gonna make him rap and we're
going to grift off the fact that this
hip-hop music is the new cool poppy
thing when he might not be the most
authentic voice for right as a rapper
there have been white rappers that
nobody questioned their [__] ever
Beastie Boys have been rapping from the
beginning and I don't remember everybody
ever coming in going oh these just some
white boys taking advantage of the movie
yeah right so just because you're doing
the thing
does it mean that you're authentic yeah
you could be doing a thing but also
grifting and we can smell it yeah we can
smell it and you can tell like there is
also something they're losers bro like
I'm sorry bro there's no way like not
everybody can tell that's a problem not
everybody can tell and that's why they
grip because they get a big group of
people that cannot tell they can't smell
the grip and then like yes that person
is saying the things that I wanted and
people don't talk to those people like
everybody's living in a bubble the
infancy of a mega person is somebody who
just feels like yo I'm struggling to how
come nobody's talking about me and the
white people in my town struggling it's
all about other people how come nobody's
seeing me and then one person comes
along and talks to that [__] toxicity
that's built up that nobody's seen them
and they're angry and they speak to that
anger and that's their [__] guy
because now if someone's speaking to
them and speaking to the anger that's
built them
you want to look past all the [__]
because they're saying that one thing
that you feel that nobody else is saying
exactly so that that is true but if you
objectively look at some of these dudes
oh yeah yeah okay you know they're
losers right like it like everybody
knows a loser yeah
yeah everybody knows like I'm sorry
everybody knows a loser like like
Crowder's wife knew he was a loser
yeah listen she did and he knows that
she knew and it drove him [__] crazy
yeah right so it's like
ah man I I think that
it's easy to get tricked when finally
there's somebody speaking the way you
feel and articulating the things that
you feel that maybe you don't know how
to say or not being broadcasting on a
big enough platform yeah but if you ask
yourself deep down like are these Your
Heroes like dang yeah and I even though
I agree with everything you just said I
think some people's existence they don't
have the same experiences to recognize
what we feel
someone may be a loser so in their eye
that is their guy
they don't see like I re I honestly feel
that because the way that some of these
people like are I think in their biggest
heart stands
I don't think so I'm telling you I don't
think so either I don't think so I
really honestly feel like that really
just maybe just because they don't have
enough time with them as like a human
being
no I'm saying like we all have different
experiences I think we're all willing to
lie to ourselves to some degree we lie
to ourselves yeah
we're all guilty of this yeah and those
people are willing to lie themselves a
little bit more about this particular
person because because that's specific
that specific thing that they're they're
speaking on is that much more important
and it's affected them that much more in
their life yeah you know it's like when
we're at war with a country right the
person that speaks the loudest about how
horrible our enemy is is probably the
person that we're going to be most drawn
to because that enemy has hurt us has
affected Our Lives has hurt our family
they've maybe killed our brothers and
sisters like so if there's someone out
there talking that [__] on the enemy
we're like yeah he's speaking it we're
not even looking at the fact that they
might also be a loser they're just
really good at talking [__] about China
whoever the [__] we're fighting which I
think what you're saying so yeah I guess
that's fair enough when you when you're
you're yeah well there's enough
desperation
the people that speak to your
desperation you give a free pass on all
the other problems that they might have
in their personality
but these [__] are losers
[Music]
it's crazy losers be with him sometimes
sometimes
sometimes they do
Sprint but I don't think they win a
marathon no it depends though well we
will see it's really depressed we're
gonna see what else we got boys Trump
doubles down can we can we see that
video bro I mean this guy go